why
so as we move forward into our
discussion of the Infinity Gauntlet and
warlock in the Infinity watch which of
course is the event that takes place
immediately after the Infinity Gauntlet
I felt like it was important to do a
lead-up to to this discussion by talking
about various characters now this first
discussion is about the one above all
and while the one above all doesn't
necessarily appear in the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline The Living Tribunal
does but in order to understand the role
that the Living Tribunal plays and the
Marvel multiverse we have to talk about
the one above all so we can have some
context and understand why the Living
Tribunal does what he does so the one
above all is an extremely obscure
character in Marvel Comics in fact the
evidence that I've uncovered all the
investigations that I've done has
pointed to the fact that the one above
all has only appeared whether by
discussion or direct appearances 17
times in the entire publication history
of Marvel Comics which is an extremely
small number it's an extraordinarily
small number especially when you
consider the idea that characters like
Wolverine have appeared in over thirteen
thousand different comics so the one
above all I guess really first appears
or the very least is first mentioned in
Doctor Strange volume 2 issue number 13
and what we see going on here is that
eternity had previously been captured by
dr. Strange's nemesis nightmare now
nightmare is of course one of the
various nemesis that dr. strange faces
that hails from a different dimension
and like all of the other guest foes
that Doctor Strange has that exists in
different dimensions nightmare is
strongest in his own dream dimension and
this is where Doctor Strange has
travelled what we see is that Doctor
Strange is able to free eternity from a
capsule that is keeping him captive at
the hands of nightmare an eternity gives
us a little bit of explanation on who he
is give us a little bit of explanation
on what his character is about now this
is not the first time that eternity
appears in Marvel Comics but it does
again give us a refresher course just
because he's not a character that
appears very often then what eternity
tells us
is that he is what but when I'm sorry he
is but one version of himself he is
simply the the version of eternity
that's confined to this universe for
every universe that exists there's an
eternity for that universe an eternity
refers to the one above all by simply
referring to him as God and all eternity
tells us here with regards to the one
above all is that he's not God that
eternity exists only in this reality but
that God rules all realities now I would
like you to pay very close attention to
this because this is actually an
instance where Marvel will simply just
use the phrase God and it's not really a
term that we will see them use to much
longer what we actually see as we jump
forward to the 1990s which is about
twenty years or so after his first
appearance and Doctor Strange volume 2
issue number 13 and keep in mind of
course we're skipping over a few a few
discussions here and there but what we
see around 1992 is warlock in the
infinity watch issue number one now to
keep from spoiling the end of the
Infinity Gauntlet although I think it's
pretty popular knowledge at this point
we see that Adam warlock is standing
trial before the Living Tribunal as well
as all the other cosmic entities due to
his actions during the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline and what's really kind of cool
about this is Adam warlock actually
flies into a fit of rage and uses the
power of the Infinity Gauntlet against
the cosmic entities but then we see the
Living Tribunal simply says let there be
order in a court and he snaps his
fingers and all of Adam warlocks power
goes away which of course indicates to
us that the Living Tribunal has power
that vastly supersedes anything that any
of the Infinity Gauntlet could possibly
wield because for each universe that
exists there's an Infinity Gauntlet for
that universe and of course this was
something that was specified to us
during Hickman's run of Fantastic Four
with the council of reeds and so on but
what we see is that the Living Tribunal
simply says that he is a representative
of forces or of a force that Dwarfs the
power of the Infinity Gauntlet of Adam
warlock and this is all we get now from
here we jump again we jump to the
Infinity war issue number two and the
Infinity war is actually a discussion
that we're not really going to go into
what we're talking about the Infinity
Gauntlet just because this ends up
sort of crazy kind of scenario and a
sort of crazy thing we have the you have
like paradise Omega and you have goddess
and you have the Magus and there's all
kinds of crazy things that go on here
and it would be a very in-depth and
extremely long discussion but what we
see here for the most part is that
warlock and a multitude of earthbound
heroes access something called the
Infinity well and the Infinity well
exists inside the domain of mistress
death and it's a source of infinite
knowledge but only for those individuals
that are able to ask the right questions
and the infinity well simply just
rehashes the trial of Adam warlock
before the Living Tribunal where he was
being held accountable for his actions
during the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
and what we see is the first time that
the one above all is actually referred
to as the one above all but what the
infinity well refers to it as is the one
who is above all and for the most part
this is how we will see the one above
all address for this from this point
going forward now one of the more
interesting concepts when it comes to
the one above all is actually during
Fantastic Four Volume one issue number
511 and what we see is that there were a
set of incidents that took place whereby
Ben Grimm was presumed to have been
killed and it travelled to heaven and we
saw that the remainders of the Fantastic
Four Reed Richards Susan storm and
Johnny Storm travelled to heaven in an
attempt to bring Ben Grimm back and what
we see is that over the course of this
this entire series that they end up in
heaven and heaven proper they end up in
the domain of the one above all and when
they actually open the door to the I
guess to where the one above all resides
that the one above all is revealed to be
Jack Kirby now this is really kind of
funny here just because I doubt that
that Mark Waid really intended for us to
actually believe that the one above all
is Jack Kirby but this is also really
kind of interesting at the same time
because for the most part there's really
no reason to say that it's not
Jack Kirby was by is by many Rockets was
by many considered to be the creator of
a lot of superheroes of the Fantastic
Four spider-man Incredible Hulk and so
on he was the Godfather of a lot of
these characters and Stan Lee was simply
the one that wrote the stories and so
for a lot of people it was an
entertaining sort of
analogy was an entertaining sort of
concept and of course Jack Kirby simply
talks to Reed Richards for a few minutes
about how the world how the universe the
multiverse exists and and what he really
sort of indicates to us here is that he
simply just set things in motion he
doesn't exactly know how they're going
to turn out but again this is actually
kind of contradicted later on when we
learn about the abilities of the one
above all one of which includes or I
guess several of which include
omniscience and omnipotence but from
here we actually jump to sensational
spider-man issue number 40 and this in
my personal opinion is the best story
involving the one above all because this
is actually part of a four-part story I
think called one more day where on May
is shot due to a failed assassination
attempt on Peter Parker and what we see
is that of course Peter Parker is
dealing with this kind of this kind of
Fallout I guess is kind of languished
due to the fact that on may very well
die who is of course a major figure in
his life and what we see is that Peter
Parker in a fit of rage punches a punch
as a dumpster when he punches the
dumpster he's sort of agonizing over his
actions and then an individual simply
just responds behind him by saying that
the dumpster will never Menace anyone
again from here we see that Peter Parker
turns around and he simply just sees a
homeless man standing there and the
homeless man says that he's really not
looking for any kind of trouble what we
see is a Peter Parker's kind of shocked
here because this individual was able to
sneak up on him without Peter Parker
spider sense going off which is
something that really shouldn't have
happened but we also see is that this
homeless man tries to tell Peter Parker
that he wants to talk to him me that he
wants to buy him food and of course he
refers to Peter Parker by name now Peter
Parker sort of blows this off he of
course talks about how Peter Parker has
been in various news magazines and so on
especially Azhar Peter Parker had
revealed himself to be spider-man which
had led to the assassination attempt on
him and of course we see that the one
above all tells Peter Parker that he's
sorry about his hands his hands are
bloody and they're damaged and then we
see that this homeless man heals Peter
Parker's hands Peter Parker surprised to
see this and he turns on Ashleigh
individual who are you he doesn't quite
who he is and this individual responds
by simply saying that Peter Parker knows
who he is and at this point we see I
guess the sort of demonstration of the
powers of the one above all possesses
where you simply just flashes makes
himself a very bright light and Peter
Parker realizes that this is the one
above all now whether or not this is
simply Peter Parker just realizing this
and I guess maybe having always had a
gut feeling that this person was the god
of the Marvel multiverse or because this
individual the one above all is simply
just given Peter Parker this knowledge
is not something that's explained to us
we're just kind of left to interpret
that on our own but what we see is that
Peter Parker in effect has a
conversation with God and of course the
first question that he asks is probably
the question that any one of us would
ask if we were faced with a scenario
where we had a loved one that's dying
and the opportunity to speak directly
with God what he says is that he's
supposed to be omnipotent that he can do
anything and so the question is why
can't he simply just heal on me
why can't he simply just make it so that
Aunt May won't die and of course the one
above all responds that if he were to
give him an answer to that question
would Peter Parker what would he do
Peter Parker sort of under this
impression that maybe Aunt May dying
it's some sort of grand scheme that
maybe there's some sort of bigger
picture going on here the Peter Parker
is quite not quite aware of but what we
see is that of course is Peter Parker
bags and Peter Parker asks the one above
all to despair on May the one above all
asks what would you do to to have this
happen would you give up being
spider-man would you give up everything
in your life in order for her to live
and Peter Parker says yes he says of
course that's something that he would do
he said he actually goes as far as to
ask the one above all would he rewrite
Peter Parker's entire story so that
somebody else was bitten by a spider and
Peter Parker never had to deal with any
of this in the first place the one above
all pauses for a second and then tells
Peter Parker that he wants to take him
somewhere and what we see is that Peter
Parker is taken to Robert Moses Beach by
the one above all which is a place where
Peter Parker had spent his youth with
his Uncle Ben and Aunt May where he used
to play and so on and so forth
Peter Parker reminisces on the fact that
they would drive there every
Sunday and of course that Peter Parker
would spend time bathing in the water
and enjoying the Sun and so on and so
forth and what we see is that the one
above all in Peter Parker begin to take
a walk down the boardwalk at this point
the one above all tells people that our
Ansari tells Peter Parker that the
suffering of people is a mysterious
thing to him the suffering of people is
something that he's really just not
quite able to grasp and this is really
interesting to us because what this
tells us is that this version this cut
this sort of God that exists in the
Marvel multiverse is not a parallel to
the judeo-christian God we're in
judeo-christianity God is a loving God
depending on which what sort of God you
choose to believe in but he's a loving
God that that would that loves humans as
though they were his own children which
according to JJ judeo-christianity that
is the case but this version of God is
simply just the individual that set
everything in motion and while I
wouldn't go as far as to say that he is
emotionally detached from humanity he
doesn't necessarily understand humanity
which of course begs the question is he
the one responsible for creating
humanity and I would say the answer to
this question is probably no that what
happened is the one above all it's
simply just I guess maybe a little spark
or had simply just initiated the the big
bang that led to the creation of
everything which would lead to the
destruction of universes the creation of
new universes and so on and so forth and
that theory that I guess that humanity
as a whole that all the species and all
the races that exist in the Marvel
multiverse are simply just a byproduct
of the evolutionary process of the
universe playing out its role I guess
sort of following its own course but
what we see is that the one above all
reveals to Peter Parker all the Peter
all the people that Peter Parker had
ever saved all the individuals that have
lived because of him you really talked
about how Peter Parker had entered and
left their lives sometimes within
minutes sometimes within seconds maybe
it was simply just swinging by and
saving a child from being hit by a car
or maybe it was his involvement in a
more in-depth storyline whereby he
sought out to save a specific individual
but that all these individuals here are
people that are either individuals who
were saved directly
or people whose lives were better
because of the fact that their loved
ones were saved Peter Parker is actually
surprised by this he doesn't realize
that all these individuals here that
this this small sampling of individuals
that are there are people that he's
saved and he's actually sort of I guess
he expressed his gratitude to the one
above all for this to really sort of get
an idea of the magnitude of all the good
that he's done in his life but in the
end it doesn't a swage his his conscious
it doesn't make him any less angry and
it doesn't make the suffering go away
and the one above all recognizes this
the one above all actually goes as far
so tell Peter Parker that he recognizes
that it doesn't make a suffering go away
and then we see the one above all sort
of explaining to Peter Parker why it is
that things are the way they are why it
is that Aunt May is teetering on the
edge of life and death he tells Peter
Parker that everybody has a role to play
that everybody has a part to play which
may include the one above all itself and
that maybe at some point along the line
the one above all may die we're not
exactly sure what the case may be here
but what we see is that the one above
all says to Peter Parker that this is
his role that this is his lot in life
that the actions that will take place
here the concept that Aunt May may very
well die will go towards him Dov being
defined as a as a more in-depth
character will go towards him B I guess
we'd be establishing himself as a more
serious individual much in the same way
that the death of Gwen Stacy had led to
Peter Parker understanding that it I
guess maybe that it wasn't enough to
simply just save people that the death
of Aunt May may lead him down a
different path the death of Aunt May may
lead him down a more serious road or it
could lead him down a more serious I
guess sinister road where he would
become a villain but what we see is of
course that Peter Parker I guess begins
to break down and tells the one above
all that he just doesn't want onme to
die that's the only real thing he wants
that at the end of the day he's really
not all that concerned about the
thousands of people that he's saved they
make him feel good but in the end all he
really wants is for his Aunt May to stay
alive and the one above all his last few
words to Peter Parker is to simply just
half faith from here we get this sort of
would be montage where we see that the I
guess the possible future or the most
likely future that will take place with
Peter Parker is Peter Parker growing old
with on I'm sorry with um Mary Jane and
of course the two of them having
children Benjamin and Mary and as far as
I understand this is actually the last
appearance that we'll see or the very
least that we have seen up into the
current day of the one above all I do
not believe there have been any other
appearances involving his character now
in terms of his relation to the Living
Tribunal what we know is that at some
point along line the living tribe you
don't had to be created because there
had to be somebody that could oversee
the balance of multiverses the balance
of universes and what we're going to do
is we're going to go ahead and lead in
with the next video and we'll talk about
the the Living Tribunal we'll talk about
the role that the Living Tribunal plays
and why it is that the Living Tribunal
is so significant to the Marvel
multiverse and I would even go as far as
to say that the Living Tribunal is
actually more significant to the Marvel
multiverse than the one above all